okay
it's just a momentary lapse of insanity
so that's like a tick for him
a tick i mean i don't know what a tick
is it's he's [ __ ] crazy
it's like it's like like people with
tourette's so sometimes they freak out
and start cussing and spitting at people
he might have a spike he might also be
in that manic mode for
30 minutes where he's talking about i
mean i've seen him tell call
tell drug dealers he's gonna [ __ ]
chop off the heads of all of their
[ __ ]
of all their like associates and he's
gonna anthrax their entire village and
i mean i have that one scene in the book
where the guy's like village frank i'm
from palm beach he goes to palm beach
then
he's gonna anthrax palm beach i mean he
just
you know and what's so funny is this
stuff that's a clip the stuff that
happens
in prison what happened on the street is
more insane because he's literally
trying to buy
airplanes he's he is actively trying to
take over
other countries he steals nearly 200
million dollars from the federal
government
and this isn't me saying this this is
i've i've got the reports there's news
you can look up frank
amadeo um you know frank amadeo fraud
and the
the it comes right up 200 million 200
nearly 200 they always say nearly
because they start adding [ __ ] really it
was about 182 million dollars
i mean as if that really matters i'm
just saying once they start adding in
all the you know fees and everything
else
they always say nearly 200 million
regardless it was 182 million dollars is
what he's
his uh restitution is i'd vote for him
can he run for president
even though he was in the sure you could
write him in could he
run for president even though he was in
prison absolutely wow emperor
i'd vote for him emperor i've listen
do you think he'd let me be his campaign
managers i would love to do his
advertising
um listen i don't a guy that thinks he's
going to be uh
emperor of the world i'm not sure how
how uh much he's going to scrutinize
anybody that supports him
uh but your emperor though you need like
a somebody who's in charge of propaganda
i would love to take that on
i would me too have fun we could do that
yeah
we could work with
i think i showed didn't i show you some
of these these are [ __ ] awesome
what what are you looking at pictures of
him right now no so what's
yeah that's amazing come on bro yeah
that's amazing look at that what are you
looking at right now describe it for me
luke uh
this looks like the best youtube
thumbnail i've ever seen he's
uh cut out in photoshop with a
like a five pixel white stroke around
him he's crossing his arms like
he's filming an hln uh reality show
he's in the desert there's missiles
firing in the background
amedeo for emperor quote i will anthrax
your entire village nice
and then also signed off quoted frank
amadeo
where it says you know amadeo for
emperor it's got the fists that make a
strong yard sign too
oh yeah that should be the thumbnail for
the podcast so what the [ __ ] his deal
he
he started out in his 20s going to law
school right he wanted to become a
lawyer
yeah that's yeah dude you got it
good stuff oh when did he get when did
he fly off the rails i mean he's in law
school he couldn't go the cia because
his dad got cancer
he had to take care of his dad right at
what point does this all start to go
sideways well you know he meets
he ends up working for a hyatt
uh hyatt legal services which is like a
bankruptcy firm it's
you know what it is it's kind of like um
it's like the the people that do your
taxes right like uh what are the central
who does your taxes what's wrong h r
block like h r block but it's for
bankruptcy it was a company that started
off they were trying to do it they had
them all over the place
he goes in he starts running the company
and he's doing and he's doing great
and he ends up marrying uh this woman by
the name of claire
and so they get married and you know he
said that
basically he's like i try to suppress
my knowledge and this is the thing he
always talked about it
like claire's always known about it and
and even in high school he said that
everybody knew about it it was kind of
like they just like laughed it off it
was kind of a quirky little thing was he
well when i'm emperor and they'd be like
emperor and he was like whoa i'm going
to be emperor of the world and i think
and they're like oh okay frank and they
kind of laugh it off
of course you're a teenager it's funny
but you're also brilliant they're going
to let it go
but it doesn't it never subsides it's a
continuing thing
and people kind of accept it as being
you know if you're kind of corky and
there's something weird about you a
little odd about you but it's also kind
of funny you're gonna let it go because
i like you
right so you're gonna let it go well it
progresses
he ends up meets claire they get married
he tries to be a normal citizen
he eventually drops into a a suit a
depression
goes into the hospital comes out and
this is back in the
80s and 90s and nobody's really thinking
depression
like they're not really what's wrong
with him he won't get out of bed he's
sick he's tired he's lethargic
what streams crashed all right
that's why we keep rolling just keep
rolling so yeah so he
he is still recording all right
what ends up happening
okay let me i'm trying to think of where
the uh
this one is okay so
what ends up happening is he ends up
getting in trouble because according to
amadeo i'm not sure that the so wait
where did where did all these
notions of being emperor of the world
come from like that didn't just come out
of thin air
where do you think he got that from no i
i think he was reading some science
fiction books when he was a kid and
like i mean he was a big fan of star
trek but i don't know he was
yeah but i mean so was i i don't think
i'm taking over the world i think he's
bipolar with
features of schizophrenia i think
there's it's a yeah he had to have
gotten that whole emperor's story from
somewhere
not necessarily a lot of bipolars or or
people with skin
he's not schizophrenic he's if he was
schizophrenic he wouldn't even be
functional
you know he just has aspects of it so
what the i don't know where that came
from
i don't know if it's just a prolonged uh
floor delusion that has continued his
whole life which is essentially what the
psychiatrist are saying
because i actually have his uh the uh
evaluation of capacity
from the from the government right here
where it's got all the
these are all the these are all the the
um
the doctors and psychiatrists that
actually
that actually look here here's the
emperor of the world right here frank
comedy
this is from this is from the uh
this is the federal government ordered
that report and he had to be
interviewed by several psychiatrists and
there's quotes in there
taken from frank and taken from the
psychiatrists if that makes sense
talking about how since he was a child
he's believed this
it's been a constant so eventually what
ends up happening is
he ends up he ends up getting in trouble
and he goes to jail he actually listened
he's supposed to get 24 months probation
what people are saying the pay pals are
sent yeah oh really pay pals are sent
people are people are paying i mean if
people are paying you got to put your
ass what do they pay for who paid for
what
yeah gotta be able to give you a touch
vacation i mean i got something i just
saw something light up
check your check your phone i got a
dollar ninety-nine dollars
yeah this is
the guy that this is a guy i know he's
well anyway he said for coffee
all right um so what happens is
i don't even know where i was neither do
i oh the the psychiatrist
psychiatrist report he was a
psychiatrist yeah that was a
psychiatrist
board but oh he gets in trouble he
eventually gets in trouble and listen
he's supposed to get
24 when this whole what are you in
trouble for the whole company basically
he went and started his own bankruptcy
company okay so he takes on a ton of
he's got a few partners takes on some
partners takes on a ton of
clients and he ends up going into a
depression they hospitalize them by time
he gets out of the hospital and goes
back to work
it's been weeks maybe a month or i think
it's been over a month or so and
basically his partners couldn't handle
the volume and there are all these
complaints and he ends up getting
disbarred because he doesn't even show
up for the
for the for the trial and what happens
is money that had been collected by them
had been he says that he wasn't in
charge of the account and they had used
the money for bills or whatever
basically was co-mingling of funds
and several people lost money and he
ended up getting disbarred no i don't
know what the police report says it
police report basically says that
there was money placed into an account
and that he essentially
um used the money to pay bills and that
he was part of the whole thing and
understood it and then when he went got
sick it caught up with him whatever
my point is oh nancy grace you don't
know who nancy grace is no
yes [ __ ] nancy grace nancy great nancy
grace
nancy grace was the prosecutor she
couldn't prosecute him
so she ended up giving it to the um the
u.s attorney nancy grace is a
she's got her own cnn show where she's
she's remember she's
like a 40 50 year old white chick with
blonde hair
like alex jones about a lady really
angry oh vicious
so she she can't prosecute him but she
hands it over to the u.s
democrat a republican i have no idea oh
i'm sure she's she's got to be what
she's mad she's just angry she's an
angry woman
she's just mad she's on cnn so she ends
up
handing it to the u.s attorney u.s
attorney indicts him he's supposed to
get
24 months when they go to
when they go to interview several people
they interview his wife and his wife
says he's got to go to jail
you can't give him 20 24 months
probation she goes he'll never learn his
lesson he's got to go to jail
wow so they say well you're going to
jail so they give them they send them to
what's called
shock boot camp they just have this boot
camp and you go there for like nine
months or something they let you out
so he goes there for nine months and
when he gets out
this is in the middle of the uh
basically the soviet union has fallen
apart this is probably around
something around 2000 something and
uh he ends up starting a company
called mirabilis that is based on
that is based on his thesis that he had
written which is called capital genesis
capital genesis is his plan for world
domination and if you
if you actually listen to him explain
the whole thing it's it's essentially
it's spectre
from like james bond it's it's a it's a
whole slew of these companies
it's great because with the cia agent in
the book breaks it all down
it's all and so does amadeo he's like
it's basically it's spectre
it's all these companies that feed off
of one another so we all own these
companies and we all give each other
favorable
favorable contracts so that we can grow
bigger and bigger and we have a shared
agenda
and we're going to buy up all these
other companies and just continue to
grow and grow and grow
and we all have a shared goal he said
the same concept is being used right now
in the um
kind of like his own little government
right and ultimately he take he'll be
able to
spread throughout the entire year
what's so funny kyle roberts said nancy
grace titty popped out on dancing with
the stars and that thing looked like a
burnt salami
[ __ ] i need to get kyle roberts live in
here
um yeah anyway uh he uh
so yeah he he ends up getting out he
starts this company they start
he starts buying up so he owns all these
companies that are all buying
serving each other he keeps go he goes
in he buys these companies that are
failing
so you he goes in and he buys the
company he either bankrupts it
yeah or puts it he might put in a
bankrupt into bankruptcy
and restructure the company or maybe he
bankrupt bankrupts it completely
pays off the debtors or you know and
turn
or maybe he restructures it and turns it
around but he's able to use the
bankruptcy laws to his advantage
so as the companies grow and grow and
this is what's interesting
i literally there is there are
transcripts
where look he's always said like people
that came to work for him
they always know like if you're a cpa
they let him know he lets them know i
have a condition
i'm i'm bipolar like everybody knows
all the lawyers that work for him know
this the um the cpas know
everybody knows they even bring in a
psychiatrist to basically monitor his
behavior
and he keeps buying he's buying these
companies he's bankrupting him he's
growing and growing he ends up buying a
bunch of
military style companies like he buys a
military company that does uh
they build um portable satellites for
the arm for the military
he ends up starting several small like
blackwater style companies
uh and i end up in the book i explained
that i basically there's like three of
them and
basically it's called tactical so i name
them all tacticals they all have
different names like tactical strategy
such and such tactical so this is
basically
tactical tactical ends up getting a
bunch of contracts
uh in iraq no in afghanistan where they
sorry they um
they protect convoys of food they
protect you know they protect um
diplomats that sort of thing his company
is his company
wow so and he's getting paid by the
government
yeah oh listen he's he's so they also do
what's
you know what black bag operations are
the cia guy goes
also black bag basically look so
you're a russian hacker okay you're like
a russian hacker we have you indicted
but we can't go into russia and get you
but then you end up going into the into
let's say
let's say you end up going into let's
whatever um
whatever you you you go to brazil or
something or you go
to norway on vacation right so
hit still we can't go in there and
kidnap somebody else
but what what happens is the state
department says or the fbi or
cia whoever they say look this guy is
going to be in norway
he's a russian citizen he's a hacker we
have him indicted if he shows up on u.s
soil
there's a two hundred thousand dollar
check waiting
so what do they they go in they watch
them for a week
and then they hit him with a [ __ ]
taser put a bag over his head throw him
in the back of the van
drive